when you grow up and you listen to all
these great artists and you cover so
many of them
but then you start to write your own
songs yeah it took me a long time to
start writing songs and I was scaring
you know I I was lucky to have a lot of
people sort of encouraging friends that
that said
you know you should write some you
should write some music or you know how
old were you when you saw you say you
started late riding your own tune that
was probably 19 or 20 when I started
started trying and probably finished my
first song around then you know and then
like the first song I ever wrote was I
think still like one of the best songs I
ever wrote in my life that's what's you
know it's amazing first one you wrote it
was called I'll back you up
should I yeah yeah if you don't mind a
tiny piece of it let me see if I can
remember how it goes It goes
[Music]
I remember thinking
I'll go on forever only knowing I'll see
you all again but I know the touch of
you is hard to remember
foreign
would you like to dance around the world
with me
I'll be
all about my own thing
and I know you're the heaviest weight
when you're not here that's all around
my head
and your lips burn while thrown from the
face of a child and in your eyes the
scene of the greatest view here do what
you will always walk where you like your
steps do as you please are you thank you
first song you ever wrote that's the
first song I ever finished I think you
know and you're thinking about a woman
yeah very a specific woman
still are you still friends you're still
in touch with that woman yeah still
friends
is your wife does your wife mind that I
mean no my wife my wife they've they've
they've hung out together no kidding I'm
I'm uh I'm very happy that it turned out
the way it did do you think in a way you
eroded to try to win her back in a way
oh of course you know you know right
I'll do I mean that's all it talks about
right but you know I'm glad I'm glad it
didn't work and you played it for it did
you say listen I've written a song about
you I want you to hear it and and she
still didn't go back to you I think she
probably liked it I think she and in
fact I know she liked the song oh but
yeah what could be more of an
aphrodisiac then yeah and then to write
a song about a woman I mean that is a
really nice song goodbye